off tonight is former senior adviser to
president barack obama
valerie jarrett she's the author of the
book finding my voice
as somebody who has actually worked in a
white house valerie
what is your reaction to the trump
administration
not cooperating with a transition or
even acknowledging
uh that they lost the election well good
evening sir
first of all i could just feel so calm
listening to president-elect biden
talk about science and sensibly
encourage people to wear a mask so i was
kind of basking in the moment there for
a moment
but on a very serious note the smooth
and orderly transition of power
depends upon the president who is
stepping down
to concede in a timely fashion so that
the president who is coming in
can get up to speed and as you know i
co-chaired
president obama and vice president
biden's transition back in 2008
and even though we disagreed with
president bush about just about
everything from policies foreign and
domestic
president bush instructed his team to
cooperate with us
immediately after president obama was
elected to make sure
that we could be up to speed by the time
the inauguration came
and in return president obama directed
us eight years later
to afford president trump the same
courtesy because it's not about the
leaders it's about the country
and we know that we'll be better off
particularly during a time in the midst
of a
pandemic in the midst of a crumbling
economy
recognizing that our enemies around the
world see us as vulnerable and
weak when this happens and so for the
good of the country
one should cooperate and the practical
implication here is is that
the transition team that has been
working for a while now
um ever since uh president-elect biden
became the nominee
cannot have the resources it needs to
pay the team it cannot have
the cooperation it needs from all of the
federal agencies
until the department of general service
the general service administration
signs a memorandum of understanding with
the transition
about confidentiality and practices of
sharing that information
and so they're kind of at a limit to
what they can do
until president trump says it's okay to
cooperate
and that puts us at risk every single
day that goes by without that
cooperation
means that the learning curve becomes so
much harder and the only silver lining
of course is that vice president
the president-elect biden had been the
vice president and so he certainly
is well steeped in the white house but
there's a lot that's been happening the
last four years and having the benefit
of that
information would help
yeah that seems like a really practical
step
there needs to be a memorandum of
understanding um from the gsa that
apparently the person in charge of that
memo
is refusing to do that so that that
actually would trigger
funding um to pay the transition staff
what damage does it do to the process
and potentially the country
um in an ability for the next
administration to get to work
if they don't have these sort of i mean
bureaucratic
uh details but they matter in place
well it just means that it's harder to
hit the ground running every day that
goes by that you don't have access
to the federal agencies and the career
folks who are working there
who as a matter of practice historically
have always shared information
with the incoming administration because
again it's not about politics
this is now is really about governing
and you can govern more effectively you
can have the smooth transition
it's kind of a hallmark of our democracy
is is that when the politics are over
you behave like adults and what's
happening now
is breaking with past practice and it's
not to say
president trump he can go and explore
his alternatives in court i will say
that
according to their lawyers uh the all of
the cases are
totally frivolous and the judges have
been throwing them out right and left
but if he wants to do that he can but in
the meantime
he should cooperate with the fact that
president
uh the president-elect trump has been
designated he has more electoral college
votes there's no way that um any amount
of recounting is going to get president
trump where he wants to go
and so this is really a waste of time
and time
that when wasted hurts the country
also the republicans need to answer the
question as to how in the same
election democrats somehow rigged it to
win the white house
but not win the senate i don't
that doesn't make sense it doesn't
compute um
and you know in in speaking of those
election results obviously
joe biden was able to win uh and it's
hard to overstate the impact of black
women on that win
how much credit does do black women
organizers and voters deserve
in your view in making sure that joe
biden became the president-elect
and kamal harris became the first woman
vice president
i'm jumping in because i can't say it
fast enough enormous
credit black women have always been the
backbone of the democratic party
but this time they really got out to
work and i will tell you
there are also leaders like stacy abrams
we got to give her her props
you know she it may not have worked out
for her in georgia to become the
governor and instead of just saying okay
i didn't win and going home what did she
do
she got to work to make sure that the
election the next election
in georgia was fairer and for the first
time that i can ever remember right
georgia's
possibly blue and we have two senate
seats coming up
that are now in runoffs which could
absolutely affect the tilt of the
balance in the senate and so
all over the country black women worked
hard they showed up they campaigned
they dragged their loved ones to the
polls and i know
that president-elect uh biden and
vice president-elect harris who said it
in her speech
said black women don't always get their
due we're going to give them their due
today she said in her speech saturday
and she tweeted it today and so i know
they are appreciated by those two and
they should be appreciated by everybody
across our country
i feel like um you know every election
cycle
we we sort of speak to um the impact of
black women
in bringing democrats over the top um in
so many
races up and down the ballot in terms of
repaying that support
what can a biden harris administration
do in terms of having an explicit black
agenda
to address many of the concerns
activists in the in the streets through
the summer
and also who lobbied congress this
summer what what can they do
uh to address those concerns uh the
folks
uh in the streets were asking for
through the summer
sure so um both president-elect biden
and vice president-elect paris i think
spoke quite
eloquently over the course of the summer
as we had protests in all 50 states
people of all backgrounds races ages
saying black lives matter the calls that
president-elect biden had with the
families who'd been affected where he
showed
his empathy the way he spoke to the
nation about just
imagine what it feels like to have to
tell your children your black children
that they have to
interact differently with the police and
everyone else just try to put yourself
in those shoes i could see the pain on
his face
and the empathy when uh president vice
president-elect senator
harris was in the senate this summer she
was instrumental in trying to push
federal legislation through
it would set some minimum parameters we
know that we shouldn't have choke holes
we know that we should not
have no knock warrants we know that we
should be making sure that the people
who
swear to serve and protect actually are
doing so and that we are
have a national data bank and i'll never
forget the story
of tamira rice who was killed by a
policeman
who was fired from a neighboring
jurisdiction and then hired by the
police in cleveland well why was why
didn't that person's name show up in a
data bank why are they getting a second
chance or a third chance or fourth
chance
there are some reasonable steps that we
could take to reimagine how we police
to make sure that there is an actual
social contract between the communities
who are being served
and those who are carrying a gun and a
badge and that work is happening at the
local level
we're seeing mayors across the country
taking this issue more seriously
looking at how we're using force looking
at ways of de-escalating which is what
the police should be trying to do
establishing a better working
relationship but it would be helpful to
have a justice department
that's led by somebody that understands
that there is still systemic racism
and patterns and practice of
discriminatory behavior that should have
consequences and you would have that
you will have that under president biden
and
vice president harris for sure and so
the one
avenue that they have in addition to
legislation is a responsible independent
justice justice department
and i know that's a top priority for
them both
absolutely it's like if you have the
right set of conditions it's a lot
easier to
talk about the issues and the policies
that might address some of those
problems
if you have an administration that
denies the existence of systemic racism
it's a lot harder to get anything done
um last minute here you worked for the
first black president in the history of
the country
um and we just made history with having
a woman
a black woman and a south asian woman
elected as the first
vice president first woman vice women of
color vice president and kamala harris
um in terms of you know just how perfect
she may have to be
um in terms of not making uh mistakes
uh in similarly to the obama family in
the white house
what are your thoughts on um that line
that she may have to walk
look she spent her whole life crashing
through glass ceilings being the first
she's used to it she's used to competing
on an uneven playing field she shouldn't
have to
but she is used to it and she's up for
the job and i think what president-elect
biden recognized is having her there
as the last person who he speaks to on
every single issue both foreign and
domestic
will enable him to make better decisions
today you saw they announced the task
force on the cobia 19.
we know the only way we're going to get
our economy back on track
is if we deal with this pandemic and she
brings to the table a very intimate
knowledge of how
disproportionately this illness has
affected the black community
communities of color around our country
she understands that small businesses
that are black owned
have gone out of business at a faster
rate she understands that the essential
workers
uh the women who have lost their jobs
again disproportionately
uh women and people of color and so
bringing that set of
life experiences and perspective to the
table will enable
him to make better decisions than to
make better decisions
and so is it a higher standard because
she's the first
absolutely is she up to that absolutely
and
closing perhaps with her words that the
advice she got from her mother is just
because she's the first
doesn't mean she's going to be only the
only i know that a big
part of her agenda is to open that door
up and so
more people who look like her get to go
through that door in the future
at all levels of government
amen to that the more representation the
better it definitely matters valerie
jarrett thank you so much for being here
and stay safe
coming up